hi everyone hello we've got something
cool to show you today and it's the fact
that we're playing music on an
oscilloscope to generate these pictures
you may ask though what is an
oscilloscope so an oscilloscope is
basically a tool that we use in the lab
to measure voltages throughout time yeah
it's a really good piece of lab
equipment to visualize what's going on
in your experiment or in a circuit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so to get this working you need your
oscilloscope on XY mode so essentially
you've got a signal and the X and Sigma
Y so if I draw those signals as being
basically sine waves so we've got one
coming in from the left ear of the
headphone and one coming in from the
right ear into channel 1 and channel 2
what is actually being displayed on the
oscilloscope is essentially a grid of
left and right amplitudes so the
amplitude of the incoming wave and the
left gives you a coordinate point and
the incoming amplitude on the right plus
it gives you a coordinate point and
that's plotted you could just have that
as a dot but since your signal is
varying you're going to get a bunch of
dots and you can draw a circle or
anything more complicated
we needed a way to get input essentially
from my phone into the oscilloscope and
so we actually started off with a pair
of headphones and then did a bit of
soldering a bit of slicing them up to
get a bit of a monstrosity here at
Jane's explained it so we start off with
some basic headphones like this now
headphones have three contact points
you have the top two which are depending
on which one's one of them is the left
one of them is the right headphone and
the bottom one here is the ground here
we have the left and the right
headphones which are then connected
provide these BNC cables to be channel
one and channel two of the oscilloscope
so this side is looking at the left
headphones sound that's coming out and
channel two here is looking at the right
here for example
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
as you might be able to see it's all
sort of on a slight diagonal slant it's
not the greatest quality of a bench so
the reason for this is as you might be
able to tell this oscilloscope is pretty
old probably made in the seventies of
the 80s and it's not as good as it used
to be it's slightly damaged so instead
of one axis being completely vertical
it's actually on a 45-degree slope so
all these spirals seem to be also on a
45-degree slope this music is all being
played directly from YouTube right now
from a guy called gyro beam and I'll
link down to his songs because he shows
you in like the highest quality what
it's supposed to look like and if you
have your own oscilloscope maybe you can
give it a try too